are you impatiently waiting for Mass
Effect Andromeda to make its way to the
pc well we're only weeks away but in the
meantime I'm going to run you through
the recently announced graphic settings
I'm Matt this is a game spot news update
and make sure to hit that like and
subscribe button for all your PC gaming
needs as you can see here Mass Effect
Andromeda supports a bevy of settings
including film dream chromatic
aberration and resolution scaling in
addition to that we've got texture
quality anti-aliasing ambient occlusion
and post process quality but that's not
all because you'll also be able to
tinker around with texture filtering and
quality settings for lighting shadows
effects mesh shaders terrain and
vegetation we'll have to wait and see
how these settings affect the game's
performance so stay tuned to gamespot
for that Mass Effect Andromeda releases
for ps4 xbox one and pc on March 21st
those on xbox one and pc can play the
game early on march 16th as long as
they're subscribed to EA or origin
access the early version of the game is
a ten hour trial that includes both the
multiplayer and single player though the
campaign component is locked to a set
number of missions if you can't wait
until then to hear more about the game
then watch our preview video that goes
in-depth on why playing on drama de has
left us worried